[Music]
foreign
New York City isn't really where you
would want to be during a monster
apocalypse or if there is a giant
creature on the loose there is a high
chance that aside from Tokyo New York
will be attacked so here in this video
we will showcase 10 giant monsters and
guide you that have attacked the Big
Apple let's get into it number one
gargantus in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe most specifically in the
Multiverse of Madness garganus is a
giant cephalopod creature that was sent
by the Scarlet Witch to kidnap America
Chavez for her trans-dimensional
traveling abilities it was based on
shimogorath but was renamed gargantus
due to some legal issues gigantos after
wreaking havoc in a street in New York
Was Defeated with Dr Strange killing it
by impaling it with a Lamppost this
cephalopod monster was like an octopus
with a big one eye on its head and has a
leg span of around 50 to 60 feet or 15
to 18 meters
or Q is a large yellow hornless dragon
and is the monster antagonist of the
1982 horror movie called Q the winged
serpent she is a Reincarnation of the
Aztec god and is brought back to life by
sacrifices performed by a sacred cult it
takes up residence in a Spire of the
Chrysler Building with frequent flights
in the midday sun to develop various
helpless New Yorkers on the rooftops Q
is eventually killed by the main
character who riddled her with bullets
the dragon here is estimated to be 50
feet or 15 meters long
number three the rideosaurus the
ritosaurus is a gigantic dinosaur
antagonist of the 1953 movie called the
Beats from 20 000 fathoms it was the
only surviving member of its species
reawakened by a nuclear bomb testing
after being buried in the Arctic for a
hundred million years in the movie The
Reader Soros has a quadrupedal built
with a row of backward facing spikes
along its back it also has crocodile in
scales on its Underside and bumpy people
like scales covering its entire body it
Rampages down the North American coast
and ends up in New York City this
creature has 200 feet or 60 meters long
and weighs in excess of 500 tons
number four Jeff this was a gigantic
worm-like alien that Jay and T thought
in the Men in Black part 2. he also
assisted in the destruction of Selena
the alien antagonist well in the movie
Jay and T first encountered Jeff the
giant worm-like alien in the subway with
a flower on its head it would seem that
the worm had grown incredibly in size
and was wreaking havoc in the New York
Subway Lines causing certain roots to be
closed off but Jeff was in fact a
long-term MIB agent it was just that his
size was causing collateral problems
because he was stated to be 200 meters
or 656 feet in length
number five Rodan this version of the
giant flying Pteranodon Kaiju that
attacked New York was the one from Final
Wars the 2004 movie of Godzilla the most
of us Rodan only reached Washington DC
as seen in king of the monsters this one
the final boss Rodan had a similar
design to the 1956 version the original
but with more pronounced arms along the
neck and legs and also skin color
similar to fire Rodan it also has
fingers with the first digit being
smaller and less Jagged haunts that slam
upwards he was seen destroying buildings
with his supersonic flight completely
decimating the skyscrapers he has a
height of 100 meters or 328 feet and a
wingspan of 200 meters or 656 feet wide
number six the leviathans seen in the
first Avengers movie leviathans are
cybernetic space whale-like creatures
used for combat by Terraces chichari
armies in 2012 they attacked New York
City but the Avengers managed to beat
them back as well as the chitari army
they were finally defeated when their
Command Center was destroyed by a
nuclear missile manually Guided by Iron
Man himself just one Fallen Leviathan
was the cause of hundreds of deaths
because of its size apparently these
leviathans were the armored shock troops
and wreaked havoc to the New York City
skyline as their size alone was around
50 to 100 meters up between 164 to 328
feet long
number seven the step-off marshmallow
man this monster appears briefly in
Ghostbusters as a form of the Sumerian
god called goza who initially takes the
form of an androgynous woman but after a
battle with the Ghostbusters goza
challenges them to choose the form of
their Destructor which they
intentionally or unintentionally think
of as a harmless tape of marshmallow man
but it appears in the 55 Central Park
West in New York City but appeared as
100 meters or 328 feet tall monster
Titan and was unfazed by the
Ghostbusters proton beams cause of its
size he was only defeated in the end
when they the Ghostbusters directed
their proton beams and pegs into the
portal closing it off
number eight Clover the Clover monster
in the movie Cloverfield is a deep sea
Kaiju that was awakened by a few
submarines that were sent down to
investigate it it emerged and rampaged
through Manhattan New York destroying
the city and eventually is killed by the
government plan to sacrifice New York
City in the hammer down protocol which
means a heavy bombing of the city it
grew to a massive size of around 90
meters or 300 feet tall by consuming a
natural substance called the seabed's
nectar the creature rampaged throughout
the city for an approximate time of 5
hours and 57 minutes destroying
landmarks and constantly battling the
military
number nine King Kong seen in the 2005
movie and also in early adaptations as
well as the original King Kong is the
loss of his species a mega primatus Kong
that rules as the Apex creature of Skull
Island he is 8 meters or 25 feet tall
and is very animalistic resembling a
gorilla but it's also one of the most
human-like and sympathetic adaptations
of the character he was taken to New
York as an exotic animal captured one
but he broke off from his chains and
went on a rampage that caused a lot of
Destruction to traffic as well as the
lower floors of many buildings in New
York he was killed Atop The Empire State
Building by fighter aircrafts riddling
him with a lot of bullets
and lastly the TriStar Godzilla or just
Zilla the iteration of the G-Man from
the 1998 movie follows the story of a
mutated iguana that grows to an enormous
size of 60 to 70 meters or 200 to 230
feet tall and terrorizes New York City
causing a lot of Destruction it was
created by French nuclear testings in
the South Pacific and it makes its way
to New York City in search of a nesting
ground instinctually deeming the
cityscape a good place to lay its eggs
once it arrives there it becomes clear
that it's not just a giant reptile but a
highly intelligent creature capable of
dodging and even outsmarting the
military's attempts to capture it or
even kill it although in the end Zilla
and its batch of newly hatched
babyzillas except for one were all
killed
so those are the 10 giant monsters that
attack New York City in movies of course
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam